das Justizministerium verkündet die
Zerschlagung des Dark webmktes
[Musik]
alphabay der Täter war ein
Technikexperte er galt als die Nummer
ein unter den
Cyberkriminellen
er besaß zwei benachbarte Häuser und
kaufte ein weiteres all seine Autos
waren
Luxusautos aber wir konnten nicht
herausfinden womit er seinen
Lebensunterhalt verdiente die Webseite
erwirtschaftete fast eine halbe
Milliarde Dollar pro Jahr wir sprechen
von 300 bis 500 Millionen Dollar pro
[Musik]
Jahr
mein Name ist Paul Craig ich bin der
Chief hacking Officer bei vage point
securities stellen Sie sich vor Sie
haben eine Menge von etwas das illegal
ist und sie wollen es verkaufen sie
können nicht auf einen onlin Markt und
es dort auflisten das Dark Web hat
dieses Bedürfnis befriedigt und ist zu
einem Marktplatz geworden auf dem
Menschen Dinge verkaufen können die
illegal
sind
dark webmärkte sind die Schwarzmärkte
des
Internets hier können wir ein Diplom von
fast jeder Schule für 0,1 Bitcoin
bekommen also etwa 1000 oder
1100 hier gibt es britische Reisepässe
mit dem Namen ihrer Wahl für 1000
britische Pfund wir sehen dass sie hier
auch ziemlich gefährliche Sachen
verkaufen wir haben auch Waffen im
Angebot ak47er
dieser Marktplatz sieht eigentlich ganz
gut aus er ist ganz neu er sieht ganz
legitim aus aber das ist alles
[Musik]
illegal 2014 wurde der berüchtigste dark
webmkt alphaay
gestet er hat über
2 Angebote und mindestens 200.000 Nutzer
weltweit die täglichen Transaktionen bei
alphabay betrugen im Durchschnitt 800000
usdoll das war der höchste Wert den das
Dark Web je gesehen
[Musik]
hatte betrachten Sie es als ebay ohne
die Auktionen oder Amazon Marketplace im
Prinzip ist es genau
dasselbe
der einzige Unterschied besteht darin
dass die Seite anonym ist und die Leute
keine Scheu haben mit illegalen waren zu
handeln alpab sah aus wie eine wirklich
einfache abgespeckte E-Commerce
Seite sehr einfach es gab nur Kategorien
und Listen mit Produkten und Preisen man
klickt auf den Link des Produktes und
kann ein Foto und eine kurze
Beschreibung sehen top bewertet sehr
stark im Labor getestet
und viele Leute machen Kommentare
darüber wie Sie Ihre Produkte heimlich
verschickt
haben es wird in einer CD-Hülle
verschickt oder in einer Vase versteckt
oder
[Musik]
so die meisten Angebote auf Alpay hatten
mit Betäubungsmitteln oder Drogen zu tun
es gab hunderte von Seiten mit Angeboten
für verschiedene
Kategorien man sah viele Bilder von
beträubungsmitteln Waffen und Dinge die
generell illegal sind die Verkäufer
stammen vermutlich vor allem aus den
Niederlanden Großbritannien Australien
Deutschland China und den
USA Marktplätze wie alphabay sind
insofern interessant als sie den lokalen
Drogenhändler auf die globale Ebene
bringen wenn man bedenkt dass der
gesamte Drogenmarkt riesig ist es geht
um Billionen von Dollar aber ihr lokaler
Drogenhändler macht nicht viel
Geld die Einnahmen sind relativ gering
weil man von Angesicht zu Angesicht mit
ihnen zu tun haben muss außerdem ist der
Verkauf von Drogen auf der Straße mit
einem hohen Risiko verbunden daher sind
diese Geschäfte in der Regel recht klein
aber durch die Verlagerung ins Internet
wird das Amazon Modell des
elektronischen Handel für illegale waren
genutzt das verschafft den Leuten
natürlich einen viel größeren Pool
potentieller Kunden auf einem viel
größeren absatzm man hat es nicht nur
mit 10 oder 15 Stammkunden zu tun sie
haben es möglicherweise mit ztausenden
oder hertausenden von potenziellen
Kunden weltweit zu tun diese Websites
haben nicht viel Inhalt außer dass hier
illegale Waren zum Verkauf
stehen im Jahr wurde der Gesamtbetrag
aller Transaktionen auf dem Dark webmkt
auf 600000 USDollar geschätzt alpabe hat
diese Zahl für seine täglichen Verkäufe
nach nur einem Jahr
erreicht es wurde schnell der größte
dark webmkt in der
Geschichte die Technologie ermöglicht
nicht nur das gedinen legitimer
Unternehmen sondern auch kriminellen
diese Technologie zu nutzen um einfach
eine bessere Rendite zu
erzielen es ist definitiv eine größere
Bedrohung für die Allgemeinheit und
deshalb war es für die Polizei eine
Priorität ist zu
[Musik]
schließen
guten Morgen heute nutzen einige der
erfolgreichsten drogenlieferanten das
sogenannte dark
Web eine Sammlung versteckter Websites
auf die man nur zugreifen kann wenn man
seine Identität und seinen Standort
verschleiert 2017 wurde die Operation
bayonet ins Leben gerufen eine
multinationale
strafverfolgungsoperation die sich gegen
alpabay richtet teilnehmende Länder USA
Niederlande Kanada Vereinigtes
Königreich Frankreich Litauen Spanien
Hongkong Thailand Zypern in
Zusammenarbeit mit
Europol während der alpabay Untersuchung
wurde klar dass die Person die für den
Marktplatz verantwortlich war den Namen
Alpha 02
[Musik]
trug Mitarbeiter von Operation bayonet
erstellten Benutzerkonten auf alphabay
um verdeckte Käufe zu tätigen wenn sich
neue Benutzer registrierten erhielten
sie eine willkommens-mail vom
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Administrator die E-Mailadresse schien
einem Kanadier zugehören Alexandre KIS
geboren am 19 oktober 1991 ein
Computergenie mit einem IQ von
142 Operation bayonet konnte die Adresse
zu cases zurückverfolgen laut seinem
LinkedIn Profil gründete er mit 17
Jahren eine Computerfirma ebx Tech er
führt in seinem Profil zahlreiche
itfähigkeiten
[Musik]
auf
das interessante an Alexandre Kes ist
dass er seine online Karriere im
Wesentlichen als jemand begann der
illegal erlangte onlinezugangsdaten
verkaufte er hatte vielleicht diese
hackermentalität er baute seinen
Marktplatz auf dieser Grundlage
auf er war technologisch interessiert er
betrieb gerne Websites eCommerce
Plattformen und er hatte ein
erfolgreiches Geschäft liegt der
menschlichen Natur man hat ein
erfolgreiches Unternehmen etwas das man
gerne macht man verschließt vielleicht
sehr schnell die Augen vor dem was im
eigenen Unternehmen vor sich geht oder
man merkt gar nicht was man
tut einige von ihnen Gründen Marktplätze
aus ich würde sagen ideologischen
Gründen sie sind der Meinung dass der
Staat den Menschen nicht vorschreiben
sollte was sie ihrem Körper zuführen
dürfen und was nicht und sie wollen
dafür eine Online Plattform zur
Verfügung
stellen
[Musik]
aber dann wenn der Marktplatz anfängt
recht gut zu funktionieren merken sie
dass das Geld
fließt es macht ihnen einfach Spaß diese
Märkte zu betreiben und genau das ist es
was zu ihrem Untergang
führt Operation bayonet erließ
Haftbefehl gegen Alex zu den 16
Anklagepunkten gehörten örung zur
Beteiligung an einer korrupten
erpresserischen Organisation
Verschwörung zum Drogenhandel und zum
Identitätsdiebstahl die Ermittlungen
führten sie nach Asien Kees Versteck wo
er alphabay betrieb die örtlichen
Behörden wurden
alarmiert
als wir von alpabay hörten dachten wir
zunächst es ginge nur um die Schließung
einer
Website ich dachte das wird schon nicht
so
[Musik]
schwierig er sagte kennst du den Makro
Großmarkt ich sagte ja das tue ichro ist
riesig und er sagte was wäre wennro
verkau wde und 50 größer
wäre würdest du das groß
finden
Cyberkriminalität verursachte weltweit
einen Schaden von 600 Milliarden
USDollar 2018 wurden über 12 Millionen
Dollar an Vermögenswerten in
cyberbezogenen Fällen
beschlagnaht die Ermittler konnten nicht
glauben was sie bei der Untersuchung
aufgedecktten sie kon nichtauben dass in
[Musik]
welk ein Krimineller der eine Webseite
im Wert von Millionen von Dollar
verwaltet tausende von Straftaten auf
einer einzigen
Plattform das war kein typischer
webseitenmanager
ธ
wir hatten erfahren dass die Website
über 100.000 Nutzer
hatte es ist ungewöhnlich dass sich so
viele Drogendealer am selben Ort und zur
selben Zeit
[Musik]
versammeln ich bekämpfe den illegalen
Drogenhandel schon seit 30
Jahren aber diese Operation warewnlichil
sieel
technie ungen ergaben dass er sich
vermutlich in Thailand aufhielt und so
schränkten wir die Suche ein die mehrere
Monate dauerte bis wir beweisen konnten
dass er in Thailand
[Musik]
war 2008 als Alexandre KIS 17 Jahre alt
war postete er in einem Onlineforum
unter dem Benutzernamen Alpha 02 am Ende
seines Beitrags gab er eine
E-Mailadresse an
es ist dieselbe E-Mailadresse die neuen
Benutzern auf dem alphabay Marktplatz
eine Willkommensnachricht
schickt er hat ein altes Hotmailkonto
benutzt was natürlich zu seiner Historie
und seinem digitalen Fußabdruck
führte er hat auch einige andere Namen
auf verschiedenen Plattformen im Dark
Web benutzt genauso wie im normalen
sichtbaren
Netz
[Musik]
wenn du einen solchen Marktplatz
betreibst besteht auch das Risiko dass
einige deiner früheren Aktionen
irgendwann auf dich zurückfallen bevor
er überhaupt davon träumte Alphabet zu
leiten hatten wir es mit etwas zu tun
das fast ein Jahrzehnt vor seiner
Verhaftung
stattfand einige dieser Dinge wurden
verwendet um verschiedene online
Personen miteinander zu
verbinden und das isth wichtig zu
bedenken was auch immer im Internet ist
es ist für immer dort wenn sie irgendwo
eine Identität verwenden ist sie da und
kann jederzeit in die Luft gehen mit all
ihren
Informationen nichts was man dort
hinterlegt wird je komplett
gelöscht was wir wissen ist dass sein
Name Alexandre K war ein Kanadier der
hier mit dieser Passnummer
lebte haben wir noch weiteregraben und
herausgefunden dass er eine
thailändische Frau
[Musik]
hat unsere Nachforschungen ergaben dass
er nicht viel getan
hat wir fanden heraus dass seine Arbeit
mit Computern zu tun
hatte also gingen wir der Sache auf den
Grund und überprüften sein Vermögen das
sehr groß
war
er besaß zwei nebeneinander liegende
Häuser und kaufte ein weiteres für 10
Millionen
[Musik]
Dollar außerdem mietete er neben den
Häusern die er besaß ein weiteres wir
fanden heraus dass er einen Lamborghini
Aventador besaß das teuerste Modell das
fast 1 Million Dollar wert war außerdem
besaß er einen
Porsche einen Mini
Cooper und ein BMW Motorrad dies sind
alles
[Musik]
Luxusfahrzeuge Alex K konnte leicht000
USDollar für ein Essen
ausgeben er war in der Lage Geld für
alles auszugeben er lebte sehr
luxuös
KIS hatte keine sichtbare Präsenz in den
sozialen Medien aber unter dem Pseudonym
Fisch prallte er mit seinem exzessiven
[Applaus]
Leben ich kannte den Kerl aus einem Chat
in dem Jungs über Partys das Leben in
Bangkok Reisen und Mädchen diskutieren
[Musik]
ich habe mehrmals mit ihm gechattet er
ist in den letzten Jahren richtig reich
geworden hatte einen Porsche Panamera
einen Lamborghini Aventador und eine
Villa
wow schönes Auto
Bruder seine Erklärung war das frühe
investieren in und Handeln mit
Bitcoin
[Musik]
es liegt in der menschlichen Natur mit
seinen Errungenschaften zu prallen aber
auf drückt das Angeben sie in den
Mittelpunkt der
Aufmerksamkeit nachdem er alpabay 2
Jahre lang geleitet hatte wurde käes
Nettowert auf 20 Millionen Dollar
geschätzt er besaß viele Häuser
Luxusautos und reiste
viel konnten nicht herausfinden womit er
eigentlich seinen Lebensunterhalt
verdiente wie ist das
[Musik]
möglich casis hat Thailand nicht ohne
Grund zu seinem Versteck
gemacht viele Länder auch in Südostasien
haben ein Gesetz dass es der Regierung
erlaubt aus Gründen der nationalen
Sicherheit Daten aus dem Internet zu
sammeln
sie nennen das rechtmäßiges
[Musik]
Abhören viele Länder in Europa machen
das viele hochentwickelte Länder
Singapur
100% aber in Thailand haben wir kein
solches Gesetz und viele Hacker in der
Welt sind froh dass das thailändische
Gesetz ist der Regierung nicht erlaubt
Informationen dem Internet auszuspen
oder zu
sammeln für sie ist das der Himmel auf
Erden 2014 wurde die Datenbank von Sony
Pictures Entertainment von einer Gruppe
namens Guardians of peace gehackt
persönliche Daten der Mitarbeiter
E-Mails und unveröffentlichte Filme
wurden online veröffentlicht der Hack
wurde nach Bangkok Thailand
[Musik]
zurückverfolgt son
ein Fall von Weltklasse Thailand war die
Quelle der IP-Adressen die Sony Pictures
Angriffen wir fanden heraus dass wir von
ausländischen Hackern gehackt worden
waren alle IP-Adressen der Angreifer
stammten von einer Universität und einem
Hotel in
Bangkok sie haben den Server
kompromittiert und sie haben diesen
Computerserver benutzt um in Sony
Pictures
einzudringen wir haben viele Fälle nicht
nur
es gab Fälle in denen wir mit dem Hacken
von Systemen anderer Regierungen in
Asien Europa und den Vereinigten Staaten
in Verbindung gebracht wurden
ausländische Hacker kommen nach Thailand
und hacken
Server wir nennen das
angriffsattribution das wird sich bald
ändern wenn ein neues
cybersicherheitsgesetz in Kraft
tritt es gibt staatlichen cyberbehörden
weitreich auf die Daten von
Internetnutzern Aktivisten haben es als
Cyber Kriegsrecht
[Musik]
bezeichnet auf Alexandre käes LinkedIn
Profil ist ein von ihm gegründetes
Unternehmen aufgeführt ebx
tech
[Musik]
die Firma ist seit Januar 2015 kurz nach
dem Start von Alpa Bay nicht mehr aktiv
die Strafverfolgungsbehörden glauben
dass IBX Tech eine Fassade für seine
illegalen Aktivitäten
war das Breaking Bad syndr Breaking Bad
ist eine sehr populäre Fernsehserie in
der man sieh wie sich die im lau der
Serie von einem sehr netten aufrechten
Bürger zu einem absolut furchtbaren
kriminellen
entwickelt mehr noch als das Geld ist es
der Nervenkitzel dieses Geschäft zu
betreiben und zu erkennen wie mächtig
man ist sie werden süchtig nach ihrem
eigenen Produkt und dieses Produkt sind
keine Drogen es ist der Nerv eine
illegale Webseite zu
betreiben alpab ist ein Online
Marktplatz der anonym im Internet
betrieben
[Musik]
wird anonym surfen funktioniert auf
hohem Niveau nach folgendem
Prinzip anstatt direkt mit Webseite zu
kommunizieren die ich bes möchte spreche
ich mit einem Vermittler der mit einem
Vermittler spricht der mit einem
Vermittler spricht und so
weiter es erlaubt Menschen illegale
Produkte oder Dienstleistungen zu
verkaufen ohne Angst erwischt zu werden
ohne Angst identifiziert zu
werden man kann sich in jedem Land der
Welt befinden und es wäre ziemlich
schwierig zu beweisen dass man derjenige
bkauft auf das Dark Web kann man nur
über anonyme Webbrowser zugreifen die
meisten benutzen die onion Router oder
kurz
Tor als erstes laden Sie Tor
herunter das können Sie kostenlos online
machen es ist sehr einfach sehr
unkompliziert herunterzuladen und zu
installieren und innerhalb von Sekunden
können Sie den Tor Browser nutzen im
allgemeinen Internet dass die Leute
kennen sieht
mancom.net.org im tornetzwerk sehen wir
nur eine Zeichenfolge und
doonion es gibt keine Möglichkeit den
domänenamen zurückzu verfolgen es ist
nur eine zufällige Zeichenfolge man kann
also ganz klar erkennen dass das im
tornetzwerk
istin
ursprünglich war Thor ein Nebenprodukt
des Office of naval research um
Geheimagenten und Spionen die
Möglichkeit zu geben anonym mit der
US-Regierung zu
kommunizieren mit der Zeit haben sich
die Anwendungsfälle
[Musik]
erweitert ein gutes Beispiel sind
Journalisten die in einem politisch
sensiblen Land recherchieren und Dinge
tun müssen die von ihrer Regierung
zensiert werden könnten
[Musik]
das tornetzwerk an sich ist also gar
nicht so
schädlich man kann Informationen
austauschen die vielleicht unreguliert
und unkontrolliert sind aber es gibt
keine Möglichkeit Produkte oder
Dienstleistungen direkt über Tor zu
kaufen aber wenn man kryptowährungen
hinzufügt die das gleiche Maß an
Anonymität und Privatsphäre bieten
erzeugen diese beiden Dinge zusammen
plötzlich den perfekten Sturm du kannst
also Produkte auflisten und Geld für
Produkte erhalten alles anonym
dark webmärkte akzeptieren nur eine Form
der Zahlung kryptowährung bitcoin ist
die beliebteste
Währung als ich 2013 an dem großen
Projekt meines Lebens gearbeitet habe
und versucht habe
herauszufinden wie ich dieses
materialarchiv an Journalisten
weitergeben
kann
wie sie die Dinge auf eine sichere Art
und Weise sehen können die nicht
kontrolliert wird stellt sich die Frage
brauche ich eine eigene
Serverinfrastruktur vielleicht lautet
die Antwort ja okay wie bezahle ich das
anonym vielleicht hat jemand wie ich
Bitcoin für so etwas
verwendet das sind 0,4 Bitcoins für
einen niederländischen
Pass das wären etwa
wenn man den heutigen Kurs nimmt der bei
etwa 1000 für einen Bitcoin liegt ja wir
akzeptieren alle
kryptowährungen kryptowährungen sind
definitiv die bevorzugte
Zahlungsmethode das ist also mein
Bitcoin Wallet und das gibt mir den
QRCode wenn mir jemand Bitcoin schicken
will Scann da einfach diesen QRCode der
dann an meine bitcoinadresse geschickt
wird und dann kommen die Bitcoin auf
mein
Konto Bitcoin kann für viele legitime
Dinge verwendet
werden es ist bloß auch die erste Wahl
für Leute die Dinge im darkweb
verkaufen es gibt keine Möglichkeit sie
zu verfolgen es gibt do keine
Möglichkeit ein kryptowährungswallet
oder Adresse mit einer Person in
Verbindung zu bringen traditionell
wurden viele Verbrechen durch das
Aufspüren von geldspuren aufgedeckt den
geldinter immer eine
Spur nehmen wir an es handelt sich um
ein einlagenkonto der Täter weiß es die
Bank weiß es viele Leute wissen ist es
ist nachvollziehbar aber bei Bitcoin
weiß nur der Täter wo das Geld
ist der Handel auf der Website war ein
virtueller Handel er war nicht
physisch der Drogenhandel oder die Daten
befanden sich alle in der
Cloud man kann also Millionen von Dollar
an jemanden am anderen Ende der Welt
schicken und im Gegenzug Waren erhalten
ohne dass jemand dazwischen etwas sieht
oder
weiß das Wachstum der kryptowährungen
hat sich direkt auf das Wachstum des
Dark Web und der Finanzdienstleistungen
im Dark Web
ausgewirkt fast 50% aller Bitcoin
Transaktionen sind auf illegale
Aktivitäten im darkweb zurückzuführen
alpabay war nicht der erste darkweb
Markt der Berühmtheit erlangte im J 2011
wurde ein Markt namens Silkroad
gegründet es war der erste der sowohl
Tor als auch Bitcoin
verwendete Drogen und andere illegale
Waren werden schon seit den 90er Jahren
im Internet
verkauft was war also bei Silk Road
anders nun Silkroad versuchte eine wie
ich es nennen würde durchgängige
anonymitätsplattform
anzubieten sie kombiniert die Anonymität
des Netzwerks durch den Einsatz von Tor
sodass ein Beobachter nicht erkennen
kann welcher Rechner sich mit welchem
Server verbindet um diese Transaktionen
durchzuführen Silk Road war eins der
größte dark Web Mark der Welt und hatte
bis zu 14 000 illegale waren im Angebot
er veränderte das Gesicht des E-Commerce
im Dark Web und diente später als Modell
für andere dark Web Märkte Silk Road
wurde nach Z Jahren vom FBI
geschlossen
ihr amerikanischer Betreiber wurde zu
lebenslanger Haft ohne Bewährung
verurteilt man hätte denken können dass
die Polizei gezeigt hat dass sie diese
Leute verhaften kann und dass es dumm
wäre in dieses Geschäft einzusteigen
weil man erwischt
wird aber genau das Gegenteil ist
passiert die Leute waren davon überzeugt
dass es eine Nachfrage seitens der
Kunden gab und das es eine tragfähige
Geschäftsidee
[Musik]
war cyberkminalität kann man am besten
mit Angebot und Nachfrage
[Musik]
beschreiben die Nachfrage auf dem Dark
Web Markt ist riesig
Ende 2014 wurde
es wurde innerhalb von Z Jahren Z mal
größer als
silkro okay also hier müssen wir ein
Konto einrichten sie verwenden PGP
Authentifizierung also ziemlich
datenschutzorientiert mal sehen ob wir
einen anderen Marktplatz finden können
okay dafür brauchen wir einen
Benutzernamen und ein Passwort ich
glaube al wariemlich einzigartig weil es
so schnell und einfach war an Bord zu
kommen und einzusteigen das hat auf
jeden Fall zum Erfolg
beigetragen anfangs war es nicht die
größte Webseite es war eine sehr
kleine sie verkauften hauptsächlich
Kreditkarten und andere digitale
Güter 2015 geriet Alp Rampenlicht weil
es gestohlene u und
[Musik]
verkaufte jetzt ist es ein gutes
Beispiel für illegale Produkte in diesem
Fall Daten die online verkauft
werden und ich kann mir vorstellen dass
sie billig zu kriegen sind weil es so
viele dieser Daten gibt man verkauft
also eine Person nach der anderen für
ein paar Dollar und es gab eine Menge
Konten die auf alphabay verkauft wurden
nicht nur von uber auch Netflix Ulu das
sind Sachen von denen ich glaube dass
sie ziemlich häufig gekauft werden weil
sie als nicht so illegal gelten aber es
ist etwas dass sie haben wollen und dann
als das Geschäft immer besser lief und
andere Verkäufer dazu kamen hat er nicht
nein gesagt als die Leute anfingen
Drogen zu
verkaufen der Betreiber verlangte zwei
bis 4% Provision auf alle Transaktionen
und verdiente damit etwa 32 000$ pro Tag
in zwei Jahren machte die Seite über
eine Milliarde Dollar in
kryptowährung es ist sehr interessant
sich zu fragen wie viele Leute man
braucht um einen dark Web Marktplatz zu
betreiben und die Antwort ist dass es im
allgemeinen überraschend wenige
sind viele der Leute die diese
Marktplätze eröffnen sind keine
drogensindikate oder Berufsverbrecher es
sind Leute mit einem starken it
Hintergrund es handelt sich hier
wirklich um
Wirtschaftskriminalität was für den
Betreiber der Plattform durchaus Sinn
macht schließlich ist der Betrieb einer
Webseite ein
itjob interessant ist aber dass man
dieselben Marketingtechniken sieht die
auch von seriösen Unternehmen eingesetzt
werden soziale Netzwerke wie Twitter
reddit und sie haben einige Social Media
Berater die im Wesentlichen ihre Marken
in diesen sozialen Netzwerken
bewerben
die meisten kryptokriminellen sind
zwischen 18 und 25 Jahre alt sie neigen
also zu illegalen Aktivitäten und haben
keine Angst vor dem Gesetz viele von
ihnen sind furchtlos und rücksichtslos
beim
[Musik]
Experimentieren sie haben ein gewisses
Ego innerhalb der
Gemeinschaft
[Musik]
das Wissen dass es der Öffentlichkeit an
Verständnis für cybersicherheit mangelt
führt dazu dass einige der Cyber
Security Hacker oder hackerxperten
denken dass sie fast so etwas wie
Superkräfte
haben und dass sie so gut sind dass
niemand sie finden
wird es handelt sich um eine Gruppe von
Kriminellen die sich herausgefordert
fühlen könnten sie einfach dass es Spaß
macht und es ein Spiel des kriminellen
Verstandes
ist es muss für diese Leute ein bisschen
aufregend sein es muss etwas sein das
Nervenkitzel bietet ein Hochgefühl
[Musik]
sozusagen im speziellen Fall des
alphabay Marktplatzes und der Reichweite
und der Anzahl der Nutzer die dieser
Marktplatz erreicht
hat wahscheinlich ein Gefühl des
Erfolgs ein Gefühl der Unantastbarkeit
weil er ein bestimmtes Niveau erreicht
hat sie haben mich bis jetzt nicht
gefunden also werden sie mich nie
fangen zu Beginn hat er nicht erwartet
dass wir so viel
Wissen er war sehr schlau er dachte
niemand würde ihm jemals auf die
Schliche kommen weil er viele
sicherheitsschichten um sich herum hatte
wir von Leuten die an diesem Fall
arbeiteten und monatelang versuchten
diese eine Person zur Strecke zu
[Musik]
bringen Operation bayonet ein von Zeh
Ländern gebildetes und von Europol
unterstütztes strafverfolgungsteam
plante eineinhalb Jahre lang die
Zerschlagung von alpabay nach 6 Monaten
war die thailändische Polizei bereit
casis zu
fassen
[Musik]
der Täter war ein Technikexperte er galt
als die Nummer ein unter den
cyberkriminell 1ber
ครับ er war sehr geschitin sich lange
Zeit den Ermittlungen
fbizien bis wir ihn in Thailand bei der
Begehung der Straftat
erwis es war eine Herausforderung alle
Beweise gegen ihn
zusammen die thailändische Polizei die
usamerikanische und andere ausländische
Polizeibeamte die an diesem Tag
zusammenarbeiteten standen unter großem
Druck wir haben noch nie in einem Fall
wie diesem ermittelt normalerweise
verfolgen wir nur die Spuren auf den
Bankkonten undige elektronische
Informationen aber noch nie mussten wir
Technologie einsetzen und eine 24
Stunden Überwachung durchführen 7 Tage
die Woche 30 Tage im Monat das war eine
ziemlich intensive Operation für
uns wie konnten wir das
erreichen wir mussten ihn auf frischer t
tappen während er die Website verwaltete
die G
wenn man sieht dass der Laptop von
jemandem auf dem Marktplatz angemeldet
ist zeigt das auch die Absicht es zeigt
dass sie tatsächlich die Person sind die
diesen Marktplatz
verwaltet Leute die torkryptowährungen
verwenden werden mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit zusätzliche
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen auf ihrem Laptop
treffen wenn dieol kommen schließen Sie
ih einfach es ist ein riesiger
verschlüsselter
Ziegelstein es gibt nichts
wasserdichteres als als Administrator
auf einem illegalen Marktplatz
angemeldet zu sein sie sind eindeutig
involviert alle zeehn Länder waren an
diesem Tag bereit nicht nur
Thailand
wir waren die erste Stufe der
Operation wir waren besorgt dass wenn
wir an irgendeinem Punkt versagen würden
alle anderen auch versagen würden denn
unsere Rolle war
entscheidend wir mussten unseren Plan
von Sekunde zu Sekunde anpassen wann
bringen wir die Kräfte rein von welcher
Seite kommen wir und wenn er herauskommt
wer wird ihn dann
festnehmen
alles musste unter Kontrolle sein bevor
wir ihn in gewaser
nehmen die Polizei inszenierte einen
Autounfall vor cases
Haus als er auftauchte um nach seinen
Sportwagen zu sehen verhafteten sie ihn
schnell normalerweise würden die Leute 5
Sekunden brauchen um zur Vernunft zu
kommen und zu reagieren deshalb mussten
wir unseren Plan innerhalb eines
begrenzten Zeitfensters
ausführen wenn er gemerkt hätte dass wir
hinter ihm seinem Computer und seinem
Telefon her waren hätte er sie
ausgeschaltet alles musste innerhalb von
9 Sekunden erledigt
werden wir mussten die Verhaftung
vornehmen und alle elektronischen Geräte
konfiszieren um sicherzustellen dass er
nicht in der Lage ist sich über andere
Verbindungen auf alphabay einzuloggen
meine Aufgabe war es dafür zu sorgen
dass wir die Kontrolle über die alphab
[Musik]
Website als wir begannen die
elektronischen Geräte wie das Notebook
zu untersenen wir
herü fühte was er die Brieftasche für
die alphabay Webseite
nannte es ermöglichte ihm die Kontrolle
über alle
administratoraktivitäten wir mussten
seinen rooty den Hauptschlüssel
entschlüsseln das waren wichtige Daten
die wir von seinem Computer holen
wollten benutzten sehr einfache
Passwörter wie Passwort oder ich liebe
dich oder Baseball oder solche
Sachen Leute die diese Marktplätze
betreiben verwenden schwerzuk knackende
Passwörter wenn man über einen passatz
nachdenkt nicht über ein Passwort z.B
einen Satz aus einem Buch dann wird es
plötzlich sehr sehr schwierig das zu
erraten der Versuch eines dieser
Passwörter zu knacken würde eine enorme
Menge
und die Verschlüsselung selbst zu
knacken ist mit der heutigen Technologie
im Grunde nicht
möglich an dem Tag an dem wir ihn fanden
er tte ih die Cybercrime Einheit auf
frischer Tat er betrieb die Website als
Administrator deshalb waren wir
zuversichtlich dass mit all diesen
beweisen die richtige
verhaftetten in thailändischen Polizei
Gewahrsam genommen er sollte an die USA
ausgeliefert und dort wegen 16
Straftaten angeklagt werden aber
Operation bayonet wurde aus den Medien
herausgehalten für Außenstehende war
alphabay einfach offline
[Musik]
gegangen die Leute dachten dass Alpha
Bay einen exitbetrug begangen hatte die
Plattform war zwar noch da aber man
konnte dort kein Geld mehr
machen die Polizei tat das um die Leute
die auf alpabay waren dazu zu bringen
woanders hinzugehen zu einem anderen
Markt alphabay Nutzer suchten nach einem
neuen Ort um mit waren zu handeln sie
wechselten zum dark Web Marktplatz Hansa
aber Operation bayonet hatte auch die
Kontrolle über Hansa übernommen sie
sammelten Informationen über alle
Verkäufer von den Servern beider
Märkte
[Musik]
dies ist eine bahnbrechende Operation
alphabay war etwa zehn Mal so groß wie
die
Seitenstraße wir sprechen von mehreren
Servern verschiedenen Ländern Hunderten
von Millionen Dollar an kryptowährung
und einem weltumspannenden
Drogenhandel
[Musik]
eine Woche nach seiner Verhaftung starb
Alexandre cases in Untersuchungshaft es
war offensichtlich
Selbstmord
[Musik]
es ist nun zwe Jahre her dass Alph Bay
abgeschaltet wurde auf schätzungsweise
30 dark Web Marktplätzen werden
weiterhin Drogen und illegale Waren
verkauft im Jahr 2018 bildeten das FBI
und Europol spezielle Teams zur
Bekämpfung von Verbrechen im
darkweb das neue iländische
cybersicherheitsgesetz erlaubt der
Regierung den Zugriff auf Daten und
Geräte es erlaubt ihr den
Internetverkehr zu überwachen und auf
private Daten einschließlich der
Kommunikation zuzugreifen ohne
[Musik]
Gerichtsbeschluss lorly Candy eine
Pädophile onlineeguppe wurde 2016
gegründet im März 2017 tauchte sie
erstmals auf dem Radar der Polizei auf
sie fand rund 10000 Fotos und Videos die
von mehr als 8000 Mitgliedern geteilt
wurden innerhalb eines Monats wurden die
vier Administratoren verhaftet darunter
auch ihr Gründer wan er wurde zu
sechseinhalb Jahren Haft
verurteilt ich bin kein Pädophiler ich
bin normal nur Gott und ich wissen dass
das alles eine Lüge ist ich wurde gezw
zuehen dass ich Opfer hatte obwoh es in
Wirklichkeit keine
[Musik]
gab
was sie getan haben war sehr unethisch
und böse weil sie Fotos von kleinen
Kindern in der Gruppe geteilt haben
darunter auch pornografische Videos
pornografische
[Musik]
Fotos schendra führte im Vorfeld ein
exklusives Interview mit wan als Teil
seines Untersuchungsberichts über den
Fall
lollyandy wenn sie nichts zu posten
hatten nahmen sie einfach ein paar
Bilder von anderen Gruppen und teilten
siean behauptete dass er internationalen
Gruppen beigetreten sei also nahm er
Fotos aus diesen Gruppen und postete sie
in der Facebookgruppe von Lolly
[Musik]
Candy die Fotos die sie teilten wurden
meist an öffentlichen Orten wie Stränden
und Zoos aufgenommen sie machten Fotos
von Kindern und teilten sie in Gruppen
das ist sehr
beunruhigend
ich habe auch eine Reihe ihrer
Unterhaltungen gelesen in der Gruppe
gaben sie Tipps wie man sich Kindern
nähen
kann ich habe im Alter von 8 Jahren mit
dem Internet
angefangen ich war
autodidakt
ich habe es mir selbst beigebracht ich
war ein ruhiger introvertierter junge
ich zog es vor mit meinen Geräten zu
spielen anstatt mit Menschen in Kontakt
zu treten als Kind liebte ich es in
internetcaff zu gehen ich liebte es so
sehr dass ich eine Stunde lang lief um
dorthin
zuelangen ich ging so of dorthin dass
ich selbst ein internetcffbetreiber
wurde ich habe meist dort
gelebt er hat wahrscheinlich viel Zeit
im Kaffee verbracht wan erzählte mir
dass er irgendwann versuchte in das deep
Web einzusteigen und den Begriff
pädophil
[Musik]
kennenlernte
er war adoptiert und von seiner Tante
aufgezogen W aber wegen finanzieller
Probleme konnte er die Grundschule nicht
[Musik]
abschließenan stammt aus einer Familie
am Rande der
Gesellschaft als wan diese Gruppe
gründete war er stolz auf sich weil er
der Gruppenleiter war und viele Leute
kontrollieren es erfüllte ihn mit Stolz
viele internationale Freunde zu
[Musik]
haben kinderie auf ly warum haben sie
sie
weitergeführt das habe ich nicht lassen
Sie es mich noch einmal klarstellen es
ging nicht darum ob ich es fortgesetzt
habe oder nicht ich war selten
aktiv erstens s es nicht so aus als
würde er sich sehr schuldig
fühlen zweitens fühlte er sich als
Opfer und drittens wollte er klarstellen
dass er nicht der Täter
sei
[Musik]
p
seit 2017 führten wir cyberpatrouillen
durch dabei entdeckten wir eine
Facebookgruppe namens lowly
Candy sie posteten
Kinderpornografie wir hatten auch
Berichte aus der Öffentlichkeit darüber
erhalten auf der Grundlage dieser
Berichte führten wir eine verdeckte
Operation
durch Candy ist einer der größten Fälle
die wir in letzter Zeit aufgedeckt
haben zum einen ist der täteran
Indonesia aber er gehörte auch zum
Verwaltungsteam anderer Pädophiler
Gruppen die wiederum mit anderen
internationalen Gruppen verbunden
waren zu Beginn unserer Ermittlungen
hatte die Facebookgruppe rund 6000
Mitglieder nachdem wir nun eine Woche
lang recherchiert hatten mussten wir
schockiert festellen dass die Zahl der
Mitglieder auf 8000 gestiegen
war es gab 10000 Fotos und
videosoto
Video wir waren wirklich schockiert als
wir die L die Facebookgruppe zum ersten
Mal sahen wie massiv der Austausch von
Daten Informationen Fotos und Videos von
Kindern
[Musik]
wurde dann waren wir natürlich
besorgt facebook war nicht Ihre einzige
Kommunikationsplattform sie gründeten
auch andere Gruppen auf WhatsApp und
telegram bei unseren Nachforschungen
fanden wir heraus dass der
whatsappgruppe Personen aus etwa 40
anderen Ländern hinzugefügt wden es gab
et WhatsApp und telegramuppen und eine
facebookgruppen aus Indonesien hatte
mehr als 8000
Mitglieder die Mitglieder von Lolly
Candy waren in mehreren WhatsApp Chats
aktiv WhatsApp begrenzt jede Gruppe auf
maximal 256 Mitglieder bei Facebook gibt
es keine Begrenzung es können also
tausende von Mitgliedern beitreten sie
wussten dass Facebook die von ihnen
hochgeladenen Inhalte zensieren und die
konnten die vulgäre Inhalte Posten
verbieten
würde
also wechselten sie zu
WhatsApp im Vergleich zu Facebook waren
die Inhalte in der whatsappgruppe noch
vulgärer sie waren so dreist echte Fotos
und Videos zu
teilen
Video wie viel um mehr von ihr zu sehen
2 okay
überwiesen
diese Apps wie WhatsApp und telegram
bieten den Nutzern die Möglichkeit in
einer privaten und sicheren Umgebung zu
[Musik]
kommunizieren deshalb können Sie in
diesem Fall z.B chatgruppen bilden die
Punkt zu Punkt verschlüsselt sind und
einfach die Informationen in einer
privaten und sicheren Umgebung teilen
die Beweise verbleiben auf ihrem eigenen
Gerät auf dem kleentsgerät und natürlich
können die Beweise in dem Moment ind dem
Sie sie löschen dauerhaft gelöscht und
zerstört
werden es gibt keine Möglichkeit sie
wiederherzustellen wir bewahren keine
Daten für strafverfolgungszwecke auf es
sei denn wir erhalten eine gültige
Anfrage zur Aufbewahrung bevor ein
Nutzer diese Inhalte aus unser Dienst
gelöscht hat wir melden alle
offensichtlichen Fälle von
[Musik]
Kinderpornografie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
he lly Candy sollte eine animegruppe
sein wir diskutierten überiler Anime und
welche Anime zu der Zeit im Fernsehen
liefen ich war nicht der ursprüngliche
Ersteller nach einiger Zeit verschwand
[Musik]
dertengliederen mich eine ne Gruppe zu
grüen
rekrutierte seine online Freunde DD tday
und shiha als coadministratoren shha und
tday waren beide
minderjährig wan war als das Gehirn und
hauptadministrator
bekannt war seine weibliche Assistentin
die die Aktivitäten der Mitglieder
überprüfte t und DD waren Mitglieder und
Gruppenadministratoren die regelmäßig
Videos und Fotos
hochluden
alle vier hatten sich noch nie im
wirklichen Leben
getroffen ich dachte dass shian
vielleicht mochte und dachte dass weil
sie einen Freund hatte ihm gehorchen
musste sie hat vielleicht gedacht dass
etwas nicht stimmt aber sie hat
mitgemacht weil ihr Freund
es war nur zum
Spaß war shiha ihre Freundin nein sie
war eine enge
Freundin ich kannte sie von
Facebook je mehr ich sie kennenlernte
desto mehr verbandte uns das Thema
Anime okay Freundschaftsanfrage gesendet
angenommen du magst Anime du
auch auf jeden Fall was magst du denn
was hast du dir angesehen wir
diskutieren über animeost Gruppe okay
kann ich mitmachen also habe ich sie in
die Gruppe eingeladen weil ich dachte
sie könnte sie verbessern und aktiver
machen aber sie hat sich darin
verstrickt jemand gab einen Kommentar ab
die Leute waren nett zu ihr haben ihr
geschmeichelt und sie hat sich hinreißen
lassen vielleicht wurde ihr gesagt sie
solle solche Dinge
hochladen damals hatte tday mich gebeten
ihn zum Admin zu machen Bro gelangweilt
Bro du hast hast eine neue Gruppe
gegründet ja habe sie gerade erstellt
mach mich zum Admin Bro vielleicht war
tday aktiver weil er noch in der Schule
war nach der Schule hatte er
Zeit er konnte sie nutzen um die Gruppe
zu
verwalten die erste Person die ich
ernannt habe war er wurde Administrator
weil wir uns sehr nahe standen wir
hatten uns im indonesischen deepweb
kennengelernt gibt es lustige Gruppen
was machst du so ich habe ein neues
Lolly Candy gestartet check mal dein
Facebook ich habe dir eine admininladung
geschickt in der Gruppe war sehr an
Anime und Anime Ost
interessiert das deep Web bezieht sich
auf alle Webseiten die von Suchmaschinen
wie Google nicht gefunden werden dazu
gehören auch alle nutzerdatenbanken und
Cloudspeicher es gab viele Anfragen eine
zweite Gruppe zu
startenan behauptet er habe die Gruppe
yegündet um über Anime zu diskutieren er
behauptet er habe nie beabsichtigt dass
sie kinderpornograische Inhalte
enthält official lowly Candy 18
plus was bedeutet 18 Plus um diejenigen
zu filtern die beigetreten sind nur
Erwachsene keine Teenager durften
posten wenn Mitglieder also über Pornos
diskutieren wollten waren sie
erwachsen
und wir haben die Regel aufgestellt dass
pornografische Beiträge nur zwischen 22
Uhr und morgens veröffentlicht werden
dürfen Artikel 41 des indonesischen
antipornografie Gesetzes verbietet die
Herstellung und Verbreitung von
Kinderpornografie trotzdem zeigen
Polizeidaten dass es in Indonesien
täglich 25000 Fälle von
kinderpornografieaktivitäten
gibt bereits eine zweite Gruppe
geschaffen in der ersten Gruppe haben
wir solche Regeln nicht
gemacht denn wir waren es schon leid uns
mit solchen Mitgliedern
auseinanderzusetzen wir konnten es nicht
vermeiden mein Handy war kaputt deshalb
konnte ich die Gruppe überhaupt nicht
überwachen im internetcaff habe ich mich
nur selten bei Facebook eingeloggt weil
ich zu der Zeit mit Spielen beschäftigt
war ich hatte keine Zeit für
Facebook ich habe mich nicht um solche
Dinge gekümmert le rauszuschmeißen das
hat mich bei der Arbeit
gestört ich habe nachts gearbeitet
tagsüber hatte ich etwas Ruhe aber ich
wurde dadurch unterbrochen jemand
schrieb bei Whatsapp hey das ist ein
Facebook Post jemand hat dies und das
getan jeden Tag meldeten sich Leute bei
mir ich wurde müde und überließ es
ihnen sie haben das Konto während ihre
Arbeit im internetcaff verwaltet ja ich
habe die Gruppe auch im Internet
gegründet als ich anfing sie zu
überprüfen dachte ich das ist nicht
richtig ich muss da Leute rausschmeißen
aber sie hatten viele Konten geklonte
Konten sie posteten ununterbrochen wir
waren es leid sie jeden Tag
rauszuschmeißen warum haben sie mit dem
zweiten Lolly Candy weitergemacht weil
ich dort meistens Empfehlungen gefunden
habe
[Musik]
ich habe dann links erstellt
spieleelinks aber ich habe ADS
benutztfly Werbung und verdientete damit
Geld die Mitglieder von Lolly Candy
tauschten untereinander
Kinderpornografie über verkürzte links
aus wenn diese Links angeklickt wurden
wurden die Mitglieder durch eine Werbung
umgeleitet sie wurden pro Klick
bezahlt für jeden der die Webseite
besuchte bekamen sie einen oder zwei
indonesische rupia sie verdienten
zwischen 70 Cent und 140 im Monat gerade
mal genug für einen Prepaid
Tarif ein anderer Administrator teilte
oft Fotos und Videos und ließ sich in
Form von Handyguthaben in Höhe von 1,50
bis 3,50 bezahlen
ich bin der Meinung dass die Absichten
der Mitglieder gemischt waren jemand der
finanzielle Probleme hatte hat
vielleicht viele Fotos geteilt und
andere taten das aus sexueller
Befriedigung sie hatte keine
Angst Kind
sindschuig wenem sie
B Angst aber was ich gesehen habe war
das
Gegenteil ich habe gelesen dass es sechs
Kinder gab die ihre Opfer waren drei
haben zugegeben dass sie sich ihnen
genähert haben damals wurde ich
gezwungen ich schwöre bei Gott das ist
die Wahrheit ich wurde gezwungen zu
gestehen und als ich nach forensischen
beweisen fragte gab es keine es wurde
nicht einmal im Prozess erwähnt sie
können es nachprüfen wenn Sie mir nicht
glauben es gab kein
be dass ich ein Opfer
hatte das ist einer ihrer
Posts es war einer meiner doppelten
Accounts viele behaupteten ich zu sein
mein ursprüngliche Account hatte kein
echtes
Foto ich habe nur mein altes spielicon
benutzt
[Musik]
WWAN behauptet dass er nicht für die
vielen facebookkonten verantwortlich ist
die mit seinem alias verknüpft
[Musik]
sind unsere Beweise belegen eindeutig
das Gegenteil von war Behauptung
hat nicht Videos geteilt und erstellt
sondern sich auch an den Kindern
vergangen zu seinen Opfern gehörten
seine Nachbarin und seine
Nichte das indonesische
Kinderschutzgesetz definiert jeden unter
18 Jahren als Kind ein umstrittenes
Gesetz erlaubt die chemische Kastration
und die Todesstrafe für Täter die
sexuelle Gewalt gegen Kinder ausüben
trotzdem gibt es in Indonesien offenbar
die höchste Zahl an Pädophilen Fällen in
Asien touristische Ziele in Indonesien
werden oft als Zufluchtsort für
Pädophile bezeichnet uniceef Indonesien
gab an dass es zwischen 2010 und 15
jedes Jahr 40.000 Opfer sexueller
Ausbeutung von Kindern gab das ist sehr
besorgniserregend
ich weiß nicht was Indonesien zu einem
Zufluchtsort für Pädophile macht
Sexualerziehung ist hier immer noch ein
Tabu es ist z.B schwierig zu erklären
wie sexueller Missbrauch selbst im
Umgang mit Fremden geschehen kann auch
die Regierung muss mehr Bewusstsein
dafür schaffen und das Gesetz
durchsetzen wir sind nicht wachsam
genug
pädophilie ist ein sehr drängendes Thema
in
Indonesien wir müssen ernsthaft damit
[Musik]
umgehen wir müssen wachsamer sein und
das Bewusstsein in der Gesellschaft
schen Kinder sollten sich trauen Nein zu
sagen sei
mutig wenn es passiert ist das nicht der
Moment höflich zu den Gästen zu sein
[Musik]
wenn man sie kennenlernt sind sie
meistens sehr sympathisch und
eloquent man würde gar nicht ahnen dass
sie Kinder belästigt oder missbraucht
haben wenn es einem niemand sagen würde
das sind genau die Eigenschaften die
Kind dazu bringen sich für eine solche
Person zu erwärmen weil sie überhaupt
nicht bedrohlich wirkt und das ist der
ganze modus operandi denn dadurch dass
Sie so freundlich und warmherzig und
zugänglich und vertrauenswürdig wirken
lassen Eltern ihre Kinder bei diesen
Leuten und dann nutzen diese Leute die
Kinder aus es gibt also eine bestimmte
Art ein bestimmtes Auftreten das diese
Personen entwickelt haben um daraus
Vorteil zu ziehen
dieser ganze Prozess ist ein Prozess des
groomings bei dem die Person eine
Verbindung zu ihnen aufbaut um sie
völlig
auszubeuten die Mitglieder sprachen
davon Kindergärtnerinnen zu werden um
leichter Opfer zu
bekommen wenn die Kinder z.B mit dem ten
fertig sind könnten sie an ihrem Schweiß
riechen sie geben tatsächlich regelrecht
an ich habe es geschafft ein Foto von
meinem Nachbarn zu bekommen ich habe es
geschafft ein Foto von meinem Neffen
oder meiner Nichte zu teilen und es ist
ihr eigener Neffe ihre eigene
Nichte wir müssen uns darüber im Klaren
sein dass wir manchmal denken dass
pädophile nur Männer sind in
Wirklichkeit können auch Frauen pädophil
sein sie können auch Befriedigung aus
dem Geschlechtsverkehr mit kleinen
Jungen
ziehen
es sind also nicht nur junge Mädchen
auch kleine Jungen können Opfer
sein hat zugegeben dass sie in der
Gruppe war aber sie hat bestritten dass
sie aktiv Fotos von Kindern verbreitet
hat sie sagte dass sie sich nicht zu
jüngeren Kindern hingezogen fühlt und
sie sich mehr zu
[Musik]
hingzogenühlte Pädophilie kann durch
genetische Faktoren verursacht
werden aber es gibt auch
Umweltfaktoren ein genetischer Faktor
ist etwas das die psychosexuelle
Entwicklung beeinflusst dadurch fühlt
sich eine Person stärker zu Kindern
hingezogen und hat es daher auf sie
abgesehen Beispiele für Umweltfaktoren
könnten sein dass ein ehemaliges Opfer
zum Täter wird und sich Rechen will oder
das Druck von Gleichaltrigen und der
Umgebung ausgeübt
wird manchmal werden bei sexueller
Ausbeutung oder sexueller Gewalt zwar
die Täter bekämpft aber die Opfer
vergessen wie bei einer Wunde wenn sie
nicht schnell behandelt wird verformt
die Narbe die Haut eine Verformung auf
psychologischer Ebene könnte später zu
etwas komplexem
werden und das könnte sie in der Zukunft
zum Angreifer
machen das gilt auch für
y
[Musik]
Hal indonesien hat eine der weltweit
höchsten Zahlen an Internetnutzern
WhatsApp und Facebook gehören zu den Top
dre Plattformen der sozialen
Medien bei der Anzahl der Facebooknutzer
liegt Indonesien weltweit auf Platz
[Musik]
4 diese Gruppe nutzt die sozialen Medien
genau zu dem Zweck für den sie
geschaffen wurden sie müssen mit anderen
Menschen kommunizieren deshalb verwenden
Sie dieselbe Strategie sie erstellen ein
Profil sie gründen Gruppen und laden
andere Gleichgesinnte ein beizutreten
und Informationen auszutauschen viele
der Tools sind leicht zugänglich und
öffentlich
verfügbar aber offensichtlich haben die
meisten Leute die diese Syndikate leiten
IT-Kenntnisse und sie kennen diese
Plattformen und sie können diese
Plattformen missbrauchen und Verbrechen
[Musik]
begehen
wussten sie nicht dass Kinderpornografie
ein Verbrechen
ist am Anfang wusste ich das nicht ich
dachte es se eine
ich habe damals zum ersten Mal davon
erfahren als ich wusste dass es ein
Verbrechen ist wollte ich die Gruppe
verlassen als ich gerade gehen wollte
wurde ich
verhaftet
ich nutze soziale Medien jeden Tag
sobald ich meine Kinder zur Schule
geschickt habe und mein Mann zur Arbeit
gegangen
ist
rrona ist Mitglied der Facebookgruppe
Fun Fun centilissis von Müttern die zu
Hause bleiben sie tauschen oft
Geschichten und Tipps untereinander
aus.com jemand hat auf sew.com über eine
Gruppe namens Lolly Candy berichtet ich
teilte sie mit meiner Gruppe von F ich
erzählte ihnen dass es eine Gruppe
namens Lolly Candy gibt die es auf
Kinder abgesehen
hat meine free haben geglaubt sie
hielten mich für paranoid und hatten
Angst dass ich einen Hoax
[Musik]
verbreite in Indonesien gibt es viele
Fake
News unser faktenchecking Team muss
fünfm am Tag über prüfen ob eine
Nachricht echt ist oder
[Musik]
nicht können Sie sich das vorstellen in
einem Monat könnten das 150 Millionen
sein das ist
[Musik]
enorm also schlossen sich vier von uns
der lolandy Gruppe an um zu sehen ob die
Nachricht echt war oder
[Musik]
nicht als ich die Gruppe das erste Mal s
war ich
schockiert weil sie Taus von
es gab Fotos von nackten
Kindern sie teilten Bilder von Kindern
im Alter von 9 Monaten bis zu 10
Jahren schockierend war dass sie nicht
nur an den Kindern in ihrer
nachtperschaft interessiert
waren sieon den Social Media Konten
ander Leute und machten sexuelle
[Musik]
Kommentare ich habe oft Bilder von
meinen Kindern auf meinen Social Media
Konten
gepostet aber seit diesem Pädophilen
Vorfall habe ich damit
aufgehört auf privat
gestellt damit nur mein Mann und
Familienmitglieder Sie sehen können wir
sammelten Screenshots Fotos von Kindern
von den
[Musik]
Opfern wir waren erleichtert und dankbar
dass die Polizei unsere Bedenken ernst
genommen
hat
[Musik]
es gab noch eine weitere schockierende
Regel in der Gruppe sie mussten beweisen
dass die Fotos und Videos die sie
teilten Originalinhalte
waren einer der Administratoren der low
candye hatesen durch das Teilen von
Originalfotos und Videos eine große
Resonanz bei den Mitgliedern erzielen
und ein beliebtes Mitglied in der Gruppe
werden
konnte zur Teilnahme an der Gruppe
gehört also nicht nur das Teilen von
Inhalten sondern auch Interaktion
Tauschhandel und Kommunikation um zu
zeigen dass man in der Gruppe aktiv
ist und wenn Sie Fotos haben müssen Sie
den Ort in den Bildunterschriften
angeben
um die Leute davon zu überzeugen dass
die Fotos echt
sind damit nicht a der grem
[Musik]
werden es gab Regeln die besagten dass
die Mitglieder immer beweisen sollten
dass die Videos oder Fotos die sie
teilten original warenem Sie den Tag das
Datum oder den der an wollten
aufschrieben dieser Schritt diente dazu
zu beweisen dass das Video wirklich von
ihnen aufgenommen wurde und nicht von
anderen Social Media Seiten
stammt facebook ist streng beim Filtern
von
Beiträgen aus diesem Grund wurden auf
Facebook bestimmte Codes verwendet z.B
die Abkürzung CP für child das war eine
Vertuschung damit der vulgäre Begriff
nicht entdeckt wird
es gibt dort aber immer noch sexuelle
Interaktionen es ist verboten es wird
automatisch von Facebook gesperrt
deswegen heißt es hier es ist besser
Inhalte zu zensieren wenn ihr etwas sehr
vulgäres Posten möchtet wie z.B
Brustwarzen oder in tetimereiche man
zensiert sie indem man eine andere Farbe
oder Emoticons verwendet man kann auch
keine blauen Links also Hyperlinks
Teilen ein blauer Link ist ein Link der
automatisch blau wird weil er aktiv
ist und sie gaben dann die Anweisung
wenn ihr links teilen wollt wie z.B
meganz dann sollte es mega Leerzeichen n
sein dann wird der Link nicht
blau nehmen wir ein Beispiel für eine
[Musik]
URL wenn diese ur z.B ein Schlüsselwort
enthält das von der Software erkannt
wird wenn die URL jedoch gekürzt wird
sind die Schlüsselwörter nicht mehr
darin vorhanden und die jeweilige
Software erkennt sie möglicherweise
nicht was wir derzeit im Internet sehen
die Suchmaschine und die von der
Suchmaschine indizierten Informationen
machen nur 5% des gesamten Internets
raus daneben gibt es das was wir das
deepweb und das Dark Web
nennen dark Web ist ein versteckter Teil
des
[Musik]
Internets sie brauchen aber Social Media
Plattformen warum weil sie andere
Mitglieder darüber informieren müssen
welche Informationen im Dark Web
verfügbar
sind wie alt ist sie ich liebe das hast
Du noch
mehr
sie haben die unzensierten Fotos oder
Videos auf speziellen Webseiten
gespeichert Mitglieder die nach dem
Ansehen des zensierten Videos daran
interessiert waren eine Vollversion zu
erhalten würden sich an den
Administrator wenden der den Link
bereitstellt der Grund warum die Zahl
der Lolly Candy Mitglieder so schnell
Anstieg auf bis zu 7000 Mitglieder lag
darin dass die von und anderen Leuten
bereitgestellten Webseiten erheit
haben sie müssen nicht ständig auf dem
Server Herumklicken um zur Domain zu
kommen es fühlt sich an als wären nur
drei Klicks nötig um zur Hauptseite zu
[Musik]
gelangen ungen versuchte die
indonesische Polizei verdeckten Zugang
zur Facebookgruppe Lolly Candy zu
erhalten es war eine Herausforderung für
uns und uns wurde klar dass wir nicht
lange verdeckt bleiben könnten weil wir
nicht in der Lage gewesen wären die
benötigten Videos oder Fotos zu teilen
so wie Sie es von den Mitgliedern
[Musik]
verlangen während die vier
Administratoren uns als Mitglieder gen
bereiteten wir Ausreden vor um Zeit zu
gewinnen und gleichzeitig nach
Informationen über die Täter zu
[Musik]
suchen wir haben Facebook um Hilfe
gebeten um uns mit Informationen zu
versorgen wir wollten prüfen ob das
Konto echt oder anonym
ist doch dann fanden wir herus dass sie
ihre echten Handynummern angegeben
hatten die Telefonnummern halfen der
Polizei die echten Konten zu
identifizieren und die Standorte der
Verdächtigen zu lokalisieren WWAN hatte
ein Foto eines fünfjährigen Kindes in
der Facebookgruppe Lolly Candy
gepostet wan hat Fotos von einem kleinen
Kind in seiner Nachbarschaft gemacht und
das Bild in der Gruppe geteilt dadurch
konnte die Polizei seinen Standort
ermitteln da auf dem Foto ein Motorrad
zu sehen und dessen Nummernschild
sichtbar
[Musik]
war wir beschlossen ein Team zu bilden
und uns in vierer Gruppen aufzuteilen um
sie gemeinsam zu
verhaften das war eine Herausforderung
für
[Musik]
uns
wie zuletzt besprochen ist es uns
gelungen die vier in lowly Candy
verwickelten Personen zu identifizieren
die wir bald verhaften
werden die vier sind an
unterschiedlichen
Orten unsere Untersuchungen haben
deutlich gemacht dass wir sie
gleichzeitig verhaften müssen und das
nicht getrennt an verschiedenen Tagen
tun
können
warum haben sie einen Befehl wenn etwas
passiert werden sie alles abschalten und
wir verlieren alle Daten die wir
brauchen damals hatten wir eineen
Nachbarn gefunden der sagte könnte in
einem bestimmten Haus
sein dann überprüften wir das Bild auf
seem facebto stellten fest dass es ein
Gebäude gab das mit dem auf seinem Foto
übereinstimmte dieses Foto bewies uns
dass es von W Haus aus aufgenommen
[Musik]
wurde verfügte über ein starkes Netzwerk
in seiner Region er erhielt den Hinweis
dass jemand nach ihm
suchte also aktualisierte er seinen
Status und sagte jemand nach ihm Suche
und
postete wenn du wirklich mein Freund
bist sei einfach
ehrlich kein Grund
herumzufagen mit diesem Update waren wir
sicher dass das Haus tatsächlich dort
war wo
war die sozialen Medien sind wieder einm
in verantwortungslose h
ger l ihre Mitglieder zum Teilen
pornograischer Inhalte ein die Polizei
nahm zwei Pädophile Täter und zwei
weitere wegen der Verbreitung der Videos
fest darunter ein 17jähriges
Mädchen es wurde im September 2016
gegründet es gab
Mitglieder neben faceb und WhatsApp gab
es noch weitere Gruppen und sie die FOS
Hand
[Musik]
gichert und
die für Mitglieder außerhalb Indonesiens
haben wir
Strafverfolgungsbehörden wie das FBI
kontaktiert das FBI identifizierte luli
Ky Mitglieder aus 63 Ländern und gab die
Daten an die örtlichen
Strafverfolgungsbehörden
weiter es ist uns gelungen Handys von
und eine Reihe von USB Laufwerken zu
sichern auf diesen Telefonen und
Laufwerken fanden wir rund 2000 Dateien
Fotos und Videos mit Bezug zu
Kinderpornographie alle vier
Administratoren von Lolly Candy wurden
wegen der Verbreitung unangemessener
Inhalte verurteilt aufgrund der
Zeitspanne zwischen der mutmaßlichen
Straftat und der Festnahme konnte wawan
nicht wegen sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs
angeklagt werden die Lolly Candy Gruppe
wurde von Facebook
[Musik]
gelöscht doch andere Gruppen operieren
weiter viele davon bestehen aus
ehemaligen Mitgliedern von Loli
[Musik]
Candy im Jahr 200 18 löste die
indonesische Polizei eine neue
Facebookgruppe von Lolly Candy
[Musik]
auf